[Música]
pese al logro que representó el rápido
desarrollo de la vacuna hay controversia
sobre la contención de la pandemia la
organización mundial de la salud asegura
que reducirá las muertes pero advierte
que no detendrá el cob y 19 y taxis
restaura la capacidad de vacunas no es
suficiente ahora mismo y con su
cobertura tampoco se parará la
transmisión
pero mientras moderna da buenas noticias
sobre la efectividad de su vacuna frente
a las variantes el instituto pasteur de
francia anunció que detenía sus pruebas
en una vacuna basada en la del sarampión
por ser menos efectiva de lo esperado el
país galo además está teniendo problemas
de suministro con las vacunas como
denuncian en este centro de estrasburgo
hay un sentimiento de frustración una
demanda muy fuerte y aunque la
organización está funcionando de forma
confiable no puede llegar a su máxima
capacidad por la falta de vacunas son un
problema que se replica en la unión
europea concretamente con astrazéneca
que redujo un 60% la entrega de dosis
para la zona euro en el primer trimestre
y la unión europea quiere que las
vacunas solicitadas y pre financiadas
sean entregadas lo antes posible
astrazéneca se escuda en las
dificultades del momento
debemos recordar que lo que estamos
tratando de hacer colectivamente nunca
se ha hecho en la historia de la
humanidad mejor están las cosas en
reinounido que anunció que casi cuatro
de cada cinco mayores de 80 años ya han
sido vacunados esto permitiría a los
adultos mayores británicos visitar las
islas seychelles en el océano índico es
el primer país en autorizar visitantes
que demuestren que ya se han vacunado